and their limited capacity come on
okay guys so welcome to another
thrilling installment of it's not a good
day to be Robert these are my supposed
to be my greatest losses but like I did
last week I don't like to just stay at
the loss so whenever I'm digesting a
really heavy loss I try to pair it with
another game that maybe I won thanks to
that previous experience you know that
was branded into me by the loss so
before we get into that silver lining I
did want to show you a game that I
played last year in the last round of
the US Open against a very strong player
alia Nisha Nick who's actually I believe
he's living here in st. Louis does
anybody know yeah I see him around I
think Washington Webster or Washington
Webster okay
well we're about to see how I could lose
to him and in fact it's it's very easy
to lose tune is Nick because he is so
good and that is very debatable
especially after you see this game so
let's just get started the game went c4
c5 Knight c3 Knight f6 Knight f3 knight
c6
and III and actually one of the hard
things about playing in the open
tournaments here in the US well depends
who you ask right is that the pairings
get posted with very little time to
actually prepare for the game some
people see this as a positive thing
because they feel like it doesn't
interfere with just the raw talent or
creativity with the game so you
sort of takes away the theoretical
element out of the equation and the two
players can just clash but other players
and I would include myself in this other
category really like to have a little
bit of time to prepare the game and it's
really not just about you know finding
some novelty and a long theoretical
variation and just crushing our opponent
in the opening I think it's also about
this other dimension of chess that's a
lot of fun which is playing over your
opponent's games and starting to
understand what kind of style they have
what kind of positions you should try to
get which ones you should try to avoid
it goes so far beyond the opening that I
really like tournaments where I get the
opportunity to prepare for the game like
a day in advance like then the parents
will get posted the night before then
I'll have a few hours in the evening to
prepare maybe a few in the morning and
then it can go to the game and see if I
can implement a strategy that I've put
together in the u.s. you don't usually
get to do that maybe at World Open
you'll get the pairings five or ten
minutes before the round starts the US
Open it's not so bad you've met him a
couple of hours maybe a few hours before
the round and that was the case with
this game it was the last round so the
round started a little bit earlier and I
had maybe a couple of hours to prepare
for the game and doing a database search
I found a game of nishan X where he
played this III move in the English
which might not seem like the main way
that white can play what usually goes
for g3 and Bishop g2 but this has really
become popular recently and the idea is
to play a sort of reversed Sicilian like
for Knight Sicilian or something like a
con Sicilian and it doesn't make sense
because the Sicilian is a very
interesting opening I think we can all
agree
and if you have an extra tempo then it
should be even more interesting
so that's really what white is aiming
for yes two thousand eight eighteen
sorry yeah of course yeah well it really
depends on my next move right so when I
prepared this opening my intention
wasn't to play a regular Sicilian right
like open Sicilian after it takes takes
because here this would be like a tamaño
of Sicilian where white is just getting
this free tempo of the knight on f3 so
this wasn't what I had in mind the move
that I played was Bishop before which
would be like a reversed Rhossili mo
yeah right
I know I know what you mean so let's say
that when you're playing with white
against the Sicilian things can get
pretty complicated but weight is always
trying to fight for the initiative right
now when you're playing with black since
you don't have that extra tempo what is
that going to translate into how serious
is that going to be okay maybe you won't
be able to fight for the initiative but
maybe you can get an equal position so
maybe I don't have to shoot as high but
I can aim for some middle ground that
makes my position as black acceptable
and I had something very specific in
mind too because it's very difficult to
get a dynamic position with white
without incurring a lot of risk right
without going into some kind of mainline
Sicilian where you're down a temple I
definitely didn't want to do that so
against Queen c2 Black has a couple of
options here one is to castle which is
what I did and this is a little bit
risky and we'll see why in a moment and
the other option and this is the one
that you'll probably encounter in most
chess books is the move Bishop takes c3
which also looks a little bit odd
actually castles looks much much more
natural but after we see what happened
in it following Castle kingside we'll
see why Bishop takes c3 makes sense and
the point is that after Queen takes now
we go Queen e7
protecting the e5 pawn and preparing d5
because now after C takes d5 Knight
takes d5 we're going to gain some Tempe
on the White Queen so for example if
white plays something like a3 after d5
pawn takes Knight takes
maybe Queen c2 and here you would run
into efore and this position already
starts to look a little bit
uncomfortable for white because well
your knight is probably gonna have to go
back to g1 and that's already going to
put you back in terms of development
right we could just castle play
something like Bishop f5 95 and try to
get the knight to d3
I think this position looks pretty
interesting for black so normally here
instead of C takes d5 white goes for the
move d4 and the idea is that after
something like e takes Knight takes
Knight takes Queen takes the arising
positions are somewhat dry and if blacks
not careful you're just gonna get a
middle game where White has the bishop
pair and you really don't have much to
show for it especially if white gets to
play d4 and Bishop b2 so this was
definitely not the kind of position that
I was looking to play against there's
Nick because he's also you know kind of
a positional beast and if you give him a
good pawn structure and the bishop here
he's just gonna squeeze you for about
six hours in the best-case scenario so
thinking about this problem I remembered
an old line I had looked at the wild
back that looked really risky but I felt
that with good preparation which I
thought I had later I realized maybe I
didn't to play Castle King side and now
White's idea is to play this very tricky
move Knight d5 the point of 95 is pretty
clear if black takes on d5 because now
after C takes this Knight has to move
and now we lose our fi pawn so that's
not good and if we take on d5 I think we
might have some pretty serious problems
with our minor pieces and why are we
winning anything with like Queen b3
maybe maybe not right because if c6 if
we go
efore then maybe your rook e8 I don't
know what's going on
it looks highly suspect though and the
fact that nobody plays this way as black
makes me think like this is probably
better to stay away from is that I
played the move rookie eight which has
the idea to take on d5 and then maybe
play something like Knight b8 right
if white does something random I could
also even consider playing efore but
here the tricky follow-up that white has
is Queen f5 yes so again the point is to
renew this idea if Knight takes pawn
takes and when the knight moves we take
the pawn on e5 so it's not easy to get
rid of the knight on d5 while white is
also threatening to ruin our pawn
structure with Knight takes f6 and if we
do something like Bishop e7 well aside
from considering whether Knight takes e5
works or not which probably doesn't
because of d6 y can just take the bishop
and Bank the bishop pair right good yep
well this is actually what happened in
the game now the difference I had
actually prepared this variation
thinking that he would go into it and
sure enough he did and here the main
line goes something like Queen takes
Queen takes pawn takes and now a3 and
after the bishop moves b4 Bishop b6 and
I think Bishop b2 there's a couple of
high-profile games that were played here
but in general this is a very pleasant
position for white because you have a
much better pawn structure on the Kings
side and you have a space advantage on
the Queen side Black's not really able
to generate much counter play
usually black will play a five to try to
undermine this clean side a little bit
and after b5 I think there's some Timman
games as whites miss love may be
defending is black yeah for sure for
sure so I decided to experiment with
this strange idea G takes f6 which still
gives me a terrible pawn structure but
at least now I'm gonna try to gain some
Tempe on the white queen while i
activate my position and yeah yeah
actually actually had played a game with
G takes f6 a few years back so I had
some experience but I never played it
against a guy that's good
and I was pretty sure he had seen this
line as well so I was kind of saying
okay let's see what you got so after G
takes f6 he played the move Queen h5 and
I played d5 this is actually how my
previous game had gone as well and the
point is that when this bishop gets
attacked now it can retreat to f8 and
help out with the kingside defense and
what I would really love to play is
efore and start driving back the white
pieces and if I could play you know
something like f5 and Queen f6 or Bishop
g7 and get my Bishop active along the h1
g8 a one h8 diagonal then actually white
might be under a bit of pressure so
white took on d5 and after
yeah this was played a3 bishop f8c takes
d5 Queen takes and now d3 and I was
already trying to remember the positions
that I had looked at because I mainly
reviewed the old game that I had played
where my opponent had played the move
Bishop d3 and the point is that after E
for the bishop can come to c2 and I
can't take on f3 because the pawn is
pinned but this is really not a good
line for white black and just take on c4
and eventually play something like 95
after takes and d3 the key for black is
to be able to play f5 and get a queen to
g6 if we manage to do this then black is
actually gonna have a pretty good
position sort of reminds me of the
sveshnikov sicilian where it looks like
your pawn structure is absolutely
horrendous but all of a sudden if you
get a pawn to f5 the the game becomes
quite dynamic and full of interesting
chances for both sides but it's
absolutely key to get f5 in so think of
this position if you don't get f5 in
it's like a special card where you never
played a5 and that's just positional
suicide so I played the move Knight a5
which is not a bad move but it's
definitely a step in the wrong direction
because if what really matters is to
play f5 I'm taking my eye off the ball
completely right I'm going for the
knight a 5
so f5 here I actually looked at f5 for a
while and I think I saw this move Bishop
d2 as a problem and the the thing is
that if I go Queen e6
Knight h4 and I can't get to g6 which is
the dream square right if I could manage
somehow to get this position and white
would take on g6 well this would be a
dream come true because I've fixed all
of my problems
so after Knight h4 I could go to h6 and
then after takes rook c1 white should be
a little bit better here because of the
better pawn structure but it doesn't
look terrible for black either right
maybe we yeah I would much rather play
this position than the other one because
here I don't I'm not getting overrun on
the Queen side in fact I might have some
counter play based on a five and a four
maybe Knight a5 at some point so I
wouldn't be too upset with this although
black still needs to be a little bit
careful
for example g3 trying to go Bishop g2 or
Bishop h3 I do have some important
weaknesses that need to be taken care of
so I don't know I was looking at
something like this and I thought maybe
whites a little bit better but not a bad
option
but the most accurate move is actually
Queen e6 and the point of Queen e6 is
that if you go Knight h4 now well this
might lead to a direct transposition so
the difference I guess would be that
well white didn't play a Bishop d2 Roxie
won but I guess in the other line you
could do a g3 right away as well yeah
yeah right so this could just be a
transposition and if white simply I
don't know develops with Bishop e2 then
f5 Knight h4 and now I can play Knight
a5 and Knight b3 I was actually fixated
during the game with getting his dark
square Bishop I wanted to throw in the
moves Knight b3 Knight takes c1 and then
continue with the f5 and queen g6 idea
if I'm able to do this it solves two big
problems
number one the possibility that white
might play b4 Bishop b2 and punish me
along this long diagonal but most
importantly it solves the main problem
that you see white having in the regular
Sicilian which is the Miss placement of
this knight on c6 when you're playing
with white against the Sicilian your
knight on c3 is your worst piece whether
you realize it or not because the knight
the Knights in general don't like
sitting in front of their pawns when
they're on a half-open file because at
some point a rook is going to get there
and you're gonna start feeling very
uncomfortable I'm sure that any of you
that have played the Sicilian or studied
Sicilian games have seen the exchange
sacrifice rook takes c3 so so this is
just an extreme example of how bad
things can get if your knight stays on
c3 or c6 in this case for too long so I
really wanted to get my knight out of
there
and nine a five-night b3 seemed like a
very tempting way to do it
however I didn't realize that white had
a hidden threat in the position so white
played Bishop d2 Knight B 3 wrote d1
Knight takes D to Knight takes D to and
now I played Queen e6 which turns out to
be a very serious blunder and loses the
game on the spot I would say so what
would you guys play it's white
so d4 here d poops
so d4 is actually the what I was most
concerned about if I had played f5 right
away because I thought well now after d4
Bishop c4 is coming right so I can't
really go each takes d4 because Bishop
c4 wins the game on the spot but I
thought well I can just go Queen e6 and
I wasn't too concerned about Bishop c4
anymore because now I just go Queen g6
and that solves all the problems so I
was thinking well you can go D takes e5
and I'm gonna be left with these
horrendous doubled isolated pawns and a
completely exposed King however this
position isn't so easy after Queen takes
e5 I'm threatening to play f4 on
doubling my pawns and trading Queens two
really important accomplishments for
black so if if white does something like
Bishop c4 just Bishop e6 and it doesn't
really change things too much also b2 is
hanging so I don't know aside from
Bishop c4 or is there anything else I
should be worried about maybe Knight c4
but this doesn't seem like it should be
such a big deal what's that
so night off three here maybe let's say
I'll bite Knight g5 do I have some do
have like a check here maybe well you're
not gonna go you're not gonna go Bishop
c4 now so I can definitely okay so Rick
d2 fair enough and I could go check
right yeah maybe I'll I have at least
the perpetual because if you ever go
king e2 I can just go back and now this
alright but I'm gonna kick you out and
and now I just I just win I just got
really ugly so so I was thinking the
only choice would be maybe Knight c4
which attacks the Queen and protects the
pawn yeah I could do something like
Queen g7 so you still can't develop the
bishop because g2 is hanging I'm still
threatening f4 maybe maybe g3 yeah if if
you go here well maybe I can throw in
this move first because you if you do
this now I have Bishop g4 and if you
castle well at least I'm gonna get rid
of this well yeah I mean that's an it's
something that we're not going to be
able to escape because this G takes f6
line is inherently complicated but it's
it's a nice question that the position
poses whether these doubled isolated
pawns are compensated by some kind of
initiative
okay so well right what if I do this
because if you go pawn takes I can go
Bishop g4 not so easy at all
so this is what I should have played but
I got scared I was like why why make my
life so complicated write all these
lines look very complicated when I can
just go Queen e6 first avoid all these
d4 ideas because of course now d4
doesn't make any sense we just go D
takes e4 and if Bishop e2 then I can go
f5 and everything's going according to
plan
most importantly I've gotten my knight
out of c6 and I'm getting ready to go
Queen g6
but something I missed something
something very important in this
position yeah yeah
so g4 is just winning because now that
I've been stripped of my f5 idea yeah
white just clamps down on the light
squares and I have no counter play
whatsoever so imagine a special code
where you never get to play f5 and white
just gets a Knight to d5 and Knight to
f5 and it's over so
yeah so right the the point is that if
Queen takes g4 I thought Oh Queen takes
g4 you know nothing happens because the
rook can't come to g1 but of course wait
just trades and then goes rook g1 and
you lose the bishop so it was one of
those moments - when you make the move
you let it go and you instantly see it
your instead o g4 of course
and sure enough he just blitzed it out
and and I knew it was over
so after g4 things don't get better no I
played f5 because I thought well if I'm
gonna lose I at least want to play f5 at
some point I just I just I just can't go
out on the street without having played
at five I just or look at myself in the
mirror
so after pawn takes Queen takes rook g1
I mean just to get an idea I mean if I
do anything else I can't even think of a
legal move huh
all right King h8 great let's start well
it all looks so nice I suppose I mean
should we go rook g1 Bishop e2 that's it
that's it even okay let's go rook g1
yeah
right and also it gives me the
possibility of meeting f5 with takes and
rook g5 so I don't have to trade queens
and now I can even start thinking about
doing something like this or bringing
the Knight to e4 it's not going to be
pretty right here okay all right now
it's worth looking at so let's say I go
Bishop e2 and now 94 okay yeah I mean
maybe
well you could you could have taken here
first but I don't know if that's gonna
make things better because the opposite
color bishops should well maybe maybe
here well but actually now yeah maybe
like here that looks like White's pieces
don't look so smart anymore so maybe
this King h8 idea was a better way of
holding on or at least I was a way of
holding on what I played was not so
you're saying maybe after Bishop e7
right here okay that looks like an inch
oh wow look at that very nice yeah so
that need for looks good yeah I mean and
if I go for then you just go Bishop c4
and f7 saying yeah so there we go
well it's good I didn't I didn't miss a
save a way to save the game that would
have just made it even worse like this
day just keeps getting worse oh yeah
it's a it's a it's a pleasure to play
with white because every move you make
is just you know clamping down on these
light squares even more so in the end I
just played f5 should I just should I
show it it's easy for it's easy for you
to look at this you're completely
detached but I'm just I'm reliving it I
volunteer is a strong word I making me
to show you this game I want to show you
the some games I won yeah okay alright
well we'll meet at the bar later
so after Queen takes we went rook g1
yeah Bishop d7 and there we go
Queen age six and it's over yeah I know
tell me about it I mean there's really
not much I can do anyway cuz if King h8
I think worth g5 was what I was looking
at I mean I can still hang out a little
bit longer but it's just a matter of
time anyway like I said let's let's move
on let's not stay fixated on this too
long yeah let's take a deep breath you
know it's okay this happens let's yeah
now let's make the best out of this
which which bar how do you do that ah
very nice
that is nice yeah I wasn't even reading
off that I was just playing this game
out of memory all right so it's
important once you have these you know
unfortunate slip-ups to really get back
on the horse I think that Kara is used
to say when you have a bad tournament
you just got to go and sign up for the
first tournament that you see out there
and and just get it behind you the worst
thing that you can do is just like sit
at home for two weeks and you know just
replace they came over and over again so
this wasn't the first tournament I
played after the US Open but it was
relatively recent I played this maybe
like a month ago and it was in an open
tournament in Argentina now my opponent
was rated about 2,000
fidei which I guess is like 2,100 USCF
but he was having an amazing tournament
he would had four out of four I had
three and a half but he had already
beaten like 324 hundreds in a row so I
was like what's going on here and I come
to this game and I make the first few
moves and he's just blitzing out all his
moves and goes Queen c2 and a castle he
goes 95 so I take off my glasses now I'm
like oh it's happening all over again
what
well I didn't think the US Open Games
got published so I started to suspect
they did because he's playing all these
moves really really fast and you know
after rookie a he goes Queen f5 and
after D six takes and takes so by now
I'm absolutely certain this guy is
prepped up to the teeth and I really
haven't let's say revisited this
variations very often after that but in
this game he played Queen c2 yeah and
this is really sort of the if you look
up this position in the database it's
the most played move because again white
used to interpret this position as
positionally oriented right where you
have the better structure and you just
want to complete your development and
get a good game now initially gave it a
much more dynamic spin and really try to
highlight the kingside problems now
hopefully I've made a good case for
blacks position despite the game where
if Black gets to play f5 things can get
really complicated in an interesting way
with Queen c2 I think white has more
modest goals but still black needs to
play energetically so the move is always
d5 because it is essential for black to
be able to tuck this bishop away on f8
and later help out on the King side so
he went a3 Bishop f8 and now after C
takes d5 Queen takes d5 and Bishop c4 so
how would you guys handle this position
yeah
okay so queen c5 is one idea and after
b4 queen e7 and if I go I'm looking at
g4 and I'm getting terrified again okay
so Queen d6 + is g4 possible I could
even try to start with Knight h4 the
point is that white wants to clamp down
on the light squares particularly this
f5 square so any move that tries to do
that should be at least interesting
Queen d7 you might play g4 anyway has
anybody seen the Fisher time I know I
know you did you just saw Fisher tamaño
from the candidates match in the
Vancouver 1971 yeah well this is
basically the same idea and the point is
to play Bishop f5 so this is going to
take the edge off of whites pressure
along light squares and I really
recommend you guys check that game out
if you've never seen it it is the
textbook example of how to win an
endgame with a good Bishop against the
bad night basically but also it happens
to be very relevant from a theoretical
point of view I mean that theory that
fishery sort of build in 1971 still
stands today so the point is that after
Bishop takes d5 Bishop takes c2 you're
really going to have a hard time
controlling that d3 square because my
next moves are probably going to be
something like rook a d8 or efore or
maybe 95 and this bishop on c2 is a real
nuisance
so in the game timeline of played well
d6 in this case d3 and now the Queen can
drop back and this makes a huge
difference to have the bishop in front
of the Queen first of all there's no g4
anymore right because after Bishop takes
I can take and just play Bishop g7 and
I'm not pinned anymore and I'm
threatening the knight and everything's
okay so I was really it was really
important to me personally not to let
white play g4 in this game I thought it
if anything I don't you know if I might
Wayne or I might lose but you're not
gonna play g4 not online watch so here
you play tonight h4 which is also a very
logical move because we're fighting for
the f5 square this was a critical moment
and I thought for a long time where
would you guys retreat with this bishop
which way because you can unde of them
well I mean they're still going to be
doubled I guess if Bishop g6 and if he
takes on g6
I won't undone but at least I'll make my
pawn chain better after H takes g6
okay and why do you like Bishop e6
better than Bishop g6
yeah so this the problem if I go to g6
is that this bishop on c4 is just going
to be unchallenged basically for the
rest of the game right it has this open
diagonal to drill me on f7 for as long
as white wants and I thought that maybe
Bishop d6 actually was interesting
because my next move would probably be
f5 and you know I'm blocking the G file
however White has a really strong
sequence here which is just to take the
bishop and after pawn takes to go h4 and
I have this hook on g6 that's gonna
allow white to open up the H file and
white will probably just go after h5
Bishop d2 and castles and the H file is
gonna be a real issue for me let alone
this bishop on c4 that's putting
tremendous pressure on f7 so I think
this would be strategically very
complicated maybe even busted for black
so the correct retreat is to challenge
the bishop on c4 and after Bishop takes
c6 what do we capture with right so pawn
takes
forever taking control over this key f5
square still I think this is what white
should have played I'm not so sure that
this is a trivial position for black
because even though the pawn structure
did get a little bit better
this is not particularly good for black
right like if white goes before what do
we do
rook a d8 that's makes a lot of sense
and do I have to go kini to maybe I do
efore and if I take that's very bold and
fear oh wait so if you Castle yeah I
guess we just go here yeah well you go
here right I can probably just go f5
this this Knight is looking very
forgotten about very neglected ok but
maybe I can do something like this or
maybe I could throw in this move first
get your night out of here so I guess 95
well but then you could go 91 actually I
mean like like that's fantastic right
but no I think that once once these
doubled pawns get on light squares and
they make up for the absence of my light
square Bishop the worst is over for
black so getting the pawn to e4 is a
major accomplishment so
yeah so I was thinking that before was
probably the way to go and after rook
the eight maybe King e2 is not the best
I don't know maybe a four here okay
and if rook the eight wait I also have
like 94 which looks very I don't know
it's like it's like the elephant in the
room like way yeah it's not when I when
I see is nights that I think I mean
those octopus is more than nice they're
just reaching out in every direction
well yeah cuz you can't go King E -
right rook date might actually be better
now so I was looking at this and if Luke
the eight maybe b5 but it still looks
sketchy because now both pawns are
hanging right D 3 and B 5 so this
doesn't help and if King to this this
efore moon looks pretty cool too
and again I mean if I get this pawn to
e4 then it's all good and I guess I
can't sacrifice the pawn in any way rook
where
oh sorry and rook d1
alright doesn't really change things too
much well maybe you could oh right this
is this guy doesn't seem to be
contributing too much so I really like
this efore 95 idea so it seems like
black it really is able to generate some
counterplay to counterbalance this bad
pawn structure so now it's my turn to be
happy because hear my opponent played
this move Bishop b5 and when he played
it like he didn't have a poker face he's
like jumped in his seat it was like ah
you know and I was like oh okay so you
blunderhead guess cuz what else would
you do that what what do you what do you
blender alright so actually we have two
good options and my question was going
to be so they both look really tempting
and I mean I had to spend like two
minutes just to calm down and and take
my hand off of the night and just really
think why one would be better than the
other because my first impulse is to
play Knight d4 like in any Sicilian
but after Knight to d4 things aren't
that easy because let's calculate so
after a takes d4 Queen takes b5 D takes
e5 now at first I thought well I have to
be crushing him here with Bishop b3
followed by rook takes e5 idiot he can
actually just you know say what do you
got
go Queen e2 because after rook takes you
can go something like Bishop e3 and and
he's getting ready to Castle kingside
what's that
you could go f5 but I'm not sure that oh
yes you can
right because here you have Queen G for
Queen to a5 and if Queen to d2 right so
it I spent quite a bit of time just
looking for something here and I just
couldn't find it White's position is
surprisingly resistant now I said okay
let's put a pin on that grenade and see
if this makes any difference because now
after pawn takes I have a couple of I
have a couple of options right I can
take the bishop right away but I could
also take on b4 so the question is which
one again we have a fork in the road we
have a fork in the road no pun intended
so what happens after Bishop takes
before so Bishop d2 right right so Queen
takes yeah I was I was looking at this
and I knew I was up at pawn and I felt
like okay this this should be better for
black especially because I might be able
to put pressure on d3 but I also thought
that this didn't look particularly great
either I felt like maybe at some point
white could do something like efore and
queen h6 and I didn't want it to be one
of those positions where I know I'm
better but I feel like I'm slowly losing
a grip on the position so I said okay
let's put a pin on the back grenade too
and see and see if Queen takes b5 offers
anything
because it would be much nicer for me to
win the d3 pawn than the b4 pawn if I
had to choose because those doubled
isolated pawns are not really going to
provide white with any kind of counter
play whereas if white gets to play efore
and clamp down on the f5 square
I know from personal experience that bad
things can happen so this is what I
ended up playing because I was just very
tempted to play rook 88 and Queen takes
d3 and there was a nice cheapo as well
that really sold it for me which is
after Bishop d2 rook edie 8 if white
plays rook a3 protecting the d3 pawn I
have this nice move Bishop takes and if
Bishop takes Queen takes and they pick
up the knight on h4 yeah and here you
really don't have a choice because I'm
threatening your rook and you can't
really put your rook along the
third-ranked so if you go back then I
can just take and then take on d3 and
and I'm up to pawns
yeah rook takes on Queen before yeah
it's probably even better right just
Queen here check here I can just take it
all right because if Queen takes Bishop
c4 it is game over so
so instead of Roque three my opponent
went rook a five and now after takes
takes rook takes this position is
basically over because I have the bishop
pair I have pressure along the D file
the knight on h4 is kind of floating
around it's not clear that he's gonna
get to clamp down and f5 and even if he
does what's the big deal I'm not gonna
get mated without Queens on the board so
there was a couple of more interesting
moments here for example after Bishop c3
what's the correct plan for black here
okay so if rook ad8 obviously I can't
take here because you win the rook on h1
but let's say that I go kini to or
castles yeah right and if you go if you
go and if you go a six I don't know
maybe I get to go B five yeah it's not
clear right because Bishop c4 and if and
it takes oh whoops
yeah so this looks pretty devastating
well but there you might have work a1
right so against oops wrong bishop maybe
I can just go here in any case it looks
like the Bishop c4 right away really
seals seals a deal but I don't think
White's idea is really to castle in
these positions white wants to keep the
King more or less close to the center
well if Bishop c4 now that King can come
this way the other option was to go be
four which looks a little bit better but
again even here
maybe f-35
but maybe now I can take this here I was
hoping it'd be easier than this
to be honest yeah yeah yeah it's getting
too complicated for her winning I
thought I was so the idea I chose was B
6 and the point is just to trade off
this pawn on b4 that's restricting my
bishop on f8 so after Bishop B takes
Bishop takes my bishops are starting to
get into the game and I can actually try
to mobilize this two against one pawn
majority so I can go like a 5 a 4 B 5 B
4 a 3 and I thought if I do that it's
just over because I'm gonna Queen the
pawn especially with the bishop on e6 if
I get a pawn to a 2 it's just easy yeah
so I thought oh I had this moment of
clarity now it's gonna be easy I
actually almost lost this game okay so
my opponent plays g4 and here is like
okay I know it should be bad but I'm
still not happy to see this move on the
board so I just played a5 rook t1 and h6
right because the threat of g5 is
surprisingly annoying because then he
takes on e5 and the dark squares really
start to fall apart so I have to stop
this and now he plays Knight f3 trying
to go h4 and g5 yeah
so
well if you play a rook here after h4
what are you gonna do okay it's kind of
kind of annoying so we we really can't
let our guard down here we have to find
the right way of dealing yeah
you can't just coast through this game
so I thought for a while
and I played King h7 and the idea was
that after h4 I can bring this rook as
backup
because after g5 I can throw in the
movie 4 and when the knight moves I just
go f5 and now when the King moves I
close everything down with h5 and at
least this is not gonna get open or
anything sure if the White Knight ever
gets staff for that might be unpleasant
but that's not gonna happen anytime soon
right this night is really far yeah okay
that's even harder so so how would you
guys play here this is a this happened
in the game so this is another critical
moment in the game and I think this is
where where black really can lay the
hammer down
rook c3 and then f6 I don't think we
really need to take any measures on the
kingside I mean I just worked really
hard to close the kingside down because
that's not the area where I feel like
I'm gonna win the game especially the
combined action of the rook on g1 and
Bishop on c3 who said f4 yeah well
Bishop c4 actually might just help white
with pinging one and make this maneuver
possible but the move Julian yeah the
move Julian just mentioned f4 really is
the correct move because this is going
to activate this bishop and also just
crack open the position for the Bishop
on c5 as well
so after takes rook F 393 rook takes off
for this is just over cuz h4 is hanging
the night is never going to reach either
f6 or f4 and I think really White's
position is collapsing now so
unfortunately I did not yeah yeah but I
did I was trying to play for some kind
of f4 ideas but I always said okay let
me just prepare it one more move you
know I'm not ready yet and that's really
when you see a good idea the more you
delay it the less strong it becomes yeah
so I played rook the eight first and
after Knight g3 King g6 King e1 and I
just started you know losing the thread
here Bishop b3 King e2 and here was
really the probably the last chance to
go f4 and after Knight takes Bishop
takes c3 so it's probably going to lead
to a winning up as a colored Bishop
endgame instead I managed to lure his
Knight to f4
after some very uninspired moves I
played before here work here and now 92
and I was like oh he's threatening 94
which was devastating yeah yeah so so
here the only move to stop Knight f4 is
Bishop d6 well if you go rook c8 right
now I I'm gonna be able to go f4 oh no
actually I have checkmate checkmate
checkmate is even better but if he goes
Knight f4 right now after takes takes
he's threatening rook c8 followed by
checkmate right here here and here
and when I saw this I was like this
isn't happening
this this can't be real so I actually
thought really hard and I was like okay
the only move is to go here so against
rook c8 I can give up the exchange and I
think this is probably still winning for
black undeservedly completely undeserved
well I mean because there was such an
easy win than AI have to resort to this
so here I go Bishop takes off for my
opponent looks at me like with the grins
like oh I got you now
and he goes rook c8 which is a terrible
blunder
I mean he's threatening checkmate in
three one two three but what did he miss
what's that
well if d1 he just takes and after I
take King e2 doesn't really change
things too much huh
brookey three and can I just can I just
take it what's that okay this is
probably this is probably even really
good for black too
we'd have to see what happens if I just
go here though I'm not taking the
Michigan I want to checkmate your king
yeah I mean you just gave me a rook and
I said no I'm gonna say yes to a bishop
ah well Bishop takes d5 is is really the
idea that he missed so there are several
moments where you can play it but after
Bishop takes he doesn't have enough time
to give checked because the bishop is
hanging so once he takes I just go f4
and now the king the King starts to run
yeah now this is just winning in it I
did win it so yes
what's it easy yeah it wasn't easy I had
to really struggle with it
but I think that these two games put
together really helped you understand
not just you know the openings but also
how you should react to a bad situation
I mean it's not like one bad game and
you should never play this line ever
again I mean I think the line is very
risky for black obviously but it is
interesting I mean if you put it to the
engine the engine sets you know go for
it you'll be fine
of course in practices a little bit
different but I don't see black going
for this line a lot and I've been
working on it and I think it's pretty
interesting so I hope it will catch on
and if you do play it and you lose don't
blame me
because I lose too sometimes alright so
thanks for listening
[Music]
you